des quais de seine entièrement piéton
voilà à quoi ressemblaient les voies sur
berges parisiennes au début des années
60 avant la politique tout auto prônée
par le premier ministre georges pompidou
un projet de voie express qui
bouleversait les habitudes des parisiens
j'ai le chemin entre on monte en référé
est mort à la chaîne chez des
fournisseurs pour cette autoroute dont
chypre
la question de la piétonisation des
voies sur berge revient dans le débat
public à partir des années 90 la mairie
de paris expérimente est alors des
journées sans voiture sur les quais une
initiative saluée par le ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque qui
préconisait un nouvel aménagement des
bords de seine
je ne vais pas décréter moi à la place
de la mairie de paris ce qu'il faut
faire dans paris je pense que l'idée est
d'avoir du nord au sud et d'est en ouest
un axe qui permet un axe qui soit
sécurisée réservée plus particulièrement
aux cyclistes et aux piétons et aux
piétons je trouve que j'étais bonne idée
une bonne idée qui emballait aussi cette
parisienne et par l'uda bhl faudra nous
faire ça tous les dimanches à un souhait
exaucé en 1995
l'ensemble des voies sur berge est
désormais fermée aux voitures tous les
dimanches la mesure est détendue au jour
férié dès 2001 après l'élection de
bertrand delanoë le nouveau maire de
paris envisageait même de fermer une
partie des quais un mois pendant l'été
c'en était trop pour certains
automobilistes
passer devant lourd et ça me tue
catastrophe comme d'habitude dans les
bois du four bears ont permis ce ne sera
pas pareil mais la conquête des voies
sur berge continue en 2010 bertrand
delanoë envisageait de piétonniser
définitivement une partie de la voie sur
berge rive gauche un bouleversement
urbain qui encore une fois ne faisait
pas l'unanimité
nous emmerdent pour faire plaisir à deux
ou trois bobo c'est en face nord en plus
de la scène les tourist ivre l'autre
côté c'est une entrave commentaires
allaient travailler dans de bonnes
dispositions mais bon c'est comme ça
en 2014 la piétonnisation des quais
devient la promesse de campagne d'anne
hidalgo
après la rive gauche la maire de paris
s'attaque à la rive droite et envisage
la fermeture à la circulation de plus de
trois kilomètres de voies le long de la
seine en plus des automobilistes
certains élus de l'opposition s'oppose
au projet début 2018 anne hidalgo ne
mâchait pas ses mots pour ses élus la
circulation automobile est prioritaire
sur la santé publique
pour cette droite parisienne et
régionales une autoroute urbaine vaut
mieux qu'un parc en coeur de ville
après quelques obstacles juridiques en
octobre 2018 la mère obtient finalement
l'avis favorable du tribunal
administratif de paris pour la
piétonnisation des quais de seine
mission accomplie pour anne hidalgo
[Musique]